[Music]
is the study of music being ruined by
the culture wars ian pace pianism
musicologist and head of music at city
university in london writes this week
that efforts to decolonize the
curriculum have gone too far
ian joins me now
ian there's a debate raging in the
classical music world at the moment what
is it well there have been a number of
recent events which have taken
musicology away from just on campuses
and has actually been have actually been
reported in the wider media
one of these most recently is the
high-profile resignation
of
a professor at royal holloway university
of london jp harper scott
on the grounds that he felt that his
profession was becoming overly dogmatic
and he felt certain sort of political
arguments were almost blackmailing
scholars in a sense
there was also been a very high profile
controversy relating to what would seem
very esoteric to some uh the analytical
work of the austrian
music theorist heinrich schenker
who also
made a range of statements and
publications which involves you know
what by any accounts are quite extreme
racist sentiments and this has led to a
whole controversy about whether we
should
teach schenker or not whether he is
acceptable
whether his political views his racial
views are somehow mirrored in his
analytical work
and there have been other things
particularly in the united states
where some have been arguing against
what would be seen as tried and tested
and long-established scholarly methods
for ascertaining truth and veracity
making sure one is scrupulous with
sources
users
uses strong arguments avoids logical
fallacies does one's homework
with some saying that instead
scholarships should be judged on its
ability to do good its ability to sort
of contribute to social justice
everything like this which i would say
is a heavy heavy politicization of
scholarship and is very dangerous in its
own way
but these
i would say are not wholly new phenomena
they've just uh
increased in volume as it were in recent
years but they go back uh several
decades to certain
certain movements which uh began around
then or at least uh began in a certain
direction around there which i think
have led to the current situation that
is true in some parts of academia
well certainly the debate over art and
artists and i remember you know wagner
obviously had some unsavory views to say
the least but you know people enjoy his
music do you think that
is now coming to um a point at which
people are now thinking more about
the the person that that and their views
rather than the music that they create
that the balance has shifted in that way
yes in many ways and oddly that's
i would say in some sense there's a
reversion to
a 19th century approach where there was
such a fixation on biography on
mythologies around artists and the link
between the biography and the work was
seen to be straightforward i don't think
it is straightforward uh
what the
there are people who were
you know
really quite despicable people who were
very fine artists and there were really
nice
ones uh with with very with with very
sort of equitable views who are very
mediocre at the same time
now there has been a whole range of
scholarship looking critically at the
relationship between biography and work
for all types of artists this is much
more advanced in the field of literary
biography than it is in musical
biography overall but i think most of
the
rigorous scholars
would be wary of
positing that you can just simply draw a
line from one thing to another an
example of this
arnold schoenberg in the year 1908
for a period his wife left him for
someone else an artist and that's the
same year that his music shifted
towards an atonal music language a music
which lacks the
gravitation around a singular pitch
which underpins most
music in the western art tradition
one of the most radical directions has
ever happened in
music now it's very easy to sort of
write this off as
just a response to a particular event in
his life but i don't think he's anything
like so simple as that
not least his wife returned to him in
time and but he still pursued this pass
for most of the rest of his
compositional career
but to respond more directly to your
question i think actually in some ways
writing potted biography or writing
writing sort of
very informal
inferences from about life and work is
much easier than grappling with the very
details and the own internal logics of
music and
i think there are tendencies within
musicology and in music education to
to avoid having to put the work in that
the latter requires because by doing the
latter then you can look at how to what
to what extent what you can discern
about the actual work
does uh relate to the biography and
that's a critical question and something
to be re-asked in every single case in
my view and ian it's not just the
political views that we're talking about
isn't it it's also the identities of the
composers you know we might be able to
make quite a fair critique that in the
west we study a lot about white male
composers and not much about people from
rest of the world or other ethnicities
and other financial backgrounds perhaps
do you think there's something in that
that we need to diversify and consider
social backgrounds when we're learning
about music as well
well i certainly think we should be
thinking about social backgrounds and
the social media in which music operated
uh at all times so how that relates to
the actual music again i think is a
complex critical question
there's no doubt that the whole history
of western classical music is dominated
by white men
i mean one can argue that uh for
before the 20th century uh
the number of people who would now be
classified outside of caucasian groups
was relatively small so it's not
surprising that you would see a white
domination but the male domination is a
wholly different matter again that
reflects uh
many other aspects of history and that's
probably true of many other musical
traditions in the world
there are extraordinarily important
musical traditions coming from china
coming from india coming from indonesia
from various places in the arab world
from various parts of africa and the
last thing i would ever want to suggest
is that these are any less
worthy of study and attention than those
in the west and then also sort of folk
and vernacular and popular traditions in
the west also
definitely repay very serious study as
well so i'm not trying to argue for the
supremacy of the western classical
tradition
but i do worry about a situation in
which that one tradition comes under
particular sort of sensor
compared to others and
whether
somehow there's guilt to be associated
with having a gravitation towards that
which i think would be seen as very
unacceptable if similar arguments were
applied to other traditions
yes absolutely i mean you would be a
perversion of the diversity agenda
really um but ian let me ask you on on
what you said just now which is that
whether or not the identity of a
composer differs changes uh contributes
to the music that they made do you think
you know different gender identities or
different ethnic identities composers of
those backgrounds compose different
types of music can we talk about you
know female music or male music is there
anything worthy to be said about that
i think those terms and those concepts
are very problematic
if i took the example um with the growth
of queer musicology in the end of the
1980s onwards
there were a lot of people quite
invested in the idea that there was a
gay music and a straight music and
debates raged about was handel gay as
composed of straight bach or schubert
compared to beethoven or gravel compared
to dbc
i sort of feel that if
someone had some information that it was
the other way around in any of those
cases they'd probably be able to find
some way of arguing that this is
reflected in the music
i'm not ruling out there could be some
sort of essential identity
to
what gay composers write so much as you
never find unity amongst an
extraordinarily diverse range
of figures but i don't think we're in
any position to be able to assert it yet
um and
well the scholar charles rosen once said
uh you might be able to observe general
tendencies but in the case he was
talking about schubert it's the
individual case that matters
and how schubert's
music reflected what he may have been
same-sex attracted
at a time in history when perhaps the
concept of being gay did not really
exist in the way that it does today
what that means in terms of his music is
a very very complex area to
deal with and i worry that there's a lot
of easy platitudes made about this
there's one musicologist who has argued
that
the harmony in schubert's music follows
different patterns to those in
beethoven's
less
less suffused with what we call dominant
harmonies which doesn't mean what you
would usually mean by dominant but it
simply means
for those who are musicians it means a
chord based on the fifth degree of the
scale
um which is a cornerstone of beethoven's
music and many others but schubert takes
a somewhat different approach
and this musical just also observed a
similar tendency in tchaikovsky who no
one doubts the sexuality of him
but then
someone else responded that you can also
find in between those two figures the
same types of harmonic progressions in
the work of france list who was about as
straight as you would get and it's quite
a womanizer
so
linking this to sexuality is you may be
able to find some cases to spot that
argument but they're often
counterexamples as well and those
equally need to be taken on board
ian pace thank you for joining spectator
tv
[Music]
you